go ahead and play the lottery whatever
but just let's remember what it is it's
a tax on the poor when you buy a lottery
ticket all of that money goes into a big
pot and in my mind it's like oh it goes
into this big pot and then whoever wins
it gets all that money that's not how it
works only like 40 of it goes to the the
actual like winner of the jackpot a lot
of the other money goes to the stores
that sell the lottery tickets the
company that like helps like to
advertise and run the lottery and of
course a giant chunk goes to Uncle Sam I
mean that's why lotteries exist that's
why governments run the lottery is
because they need to raise extra money
people don't like taxes so the lottery
just makes taxes fun that money usually
goes into public programs like parks and
education or in the case of Nebraska it
goes into like funding their state fair
okay the fact is the lottery is a tax
and it is a tax that's born particularly
by people who have less education who
live in poorer neighborhoods and whose
money goes into the big lottery jackpot
and doesn't actually come back to
benefit their neighborhood it's not like
a tax that actually benefits them in any
material way so